yet another film that got panned for
being too scary Honey I Shrunk the Kids
and yeah again I'm not gonna act like I
don't see where they're coming from
everything in this movie is huge
gigantic and trying to kill you it's
totally understandable but again I think
a lot of critics really underestimate
how much kids could take because this
movie was a big hit and audiences loved
it
not only did it have a lot of impressive
sets and some damn good effects at the
time but it had some funny side
characters an OK cast of main characters
it was a great big budget version of
something that we've seen plenty of
times before but not quite to the scale
rick moranis is a scientist who's trying
to create a machine that you guessed it
can shrink things but everything he
tries to shrink down keeps blowing up in
his face literally but that all changes
when the neighbor's kid accidentally
knocks a baseball into the machine which
figures out what the missing element
so both the neighbors kids and the
scientist kids all get shrunken down
they get taken out with the trash and
all they have to do is cross the back
yard in order to get home only now the
backyard is a jungle they come across
everything bees ants lawnmowers
sprinklers everyday little mundane
things are now psychotic killers trying
to destroy them when I was a kid I
really enjoyed this film and even today
I do find I like it but nowadays I find
I enjoy more the technicals of it like
the says or the animatronics or the
stop-motion things like that the story
and characters aren't bad they're just
kind of okay with the exception maybe
Rick Moranis and Matt Frewer as the
neighbors the kids are kind of generic
kid you get your geeky little dweeb you
have the jock you have the pretty girl
you have the pretty boy of course
they're gonna fall in love it's fine I
mean I can't think of anything that was
really painful to go through I guess I
would have liked a little bit more
though but again that's not the focus
the focus is the effects that's pretty
much how the story is told characters
walk talked a bit then we come across in
effect characters talk walk a bit then
they come across an effect and it's fine
that's what most kids want to see and I
guess that's what most adults want to
see - but terms of character I did find
I enjoyed the stuff with Rick Moranis
and the neighbors a lot more that's
where the main comedy seemed to come
from
everything else are falls into the
wouldn't it be neat category not that
these characters are bad but you don't
care as much what happens to them as
much as hey would it be cool if I was
there I want to eat that giant cookie I
want to ride that giant and I want to do
all this stuff except maybe the stuff
that's trying to kill you that we could
skip so overall it's an OK film with
some really cool effects in it if the
effects weren't there it'd probably be a
bit of a bore but they are and they're
impressive and the story leads to a lot
of great grand effects and they're fun
to check out some scenes can be a little
intense for younger kids but yeah
nothing bloody nothing really that
terrifying it's just intense check it
out for yourself and find out